the mall leading to buckingham palace
was already busy with well-wishers and
sightseers from early afternoon union
jag flags everywhere
this family came from gloucester to
enjoy the festivities
i think for me it's because of it's
something that my children are never
going to experience so it's something
you know it's such a historical thing
that we need to be in london
and among the crowd one or two who've
actually met the queen i know personally
the queen i've been the ambassador of
the democratic republic of congo in this
country
i met the queen
more than 10 times in my life
every time when
i come back to her
she remember all the things we did or we
we spoke six months before
and she came back as it was yesterday
basking in warm sunshine down here on
the maryland central london the
celebrations for the queen's platinum
jubilee are invoking a kind of sense of
national well-being that seems a world
away from the day-to-day problems of
high energy costs and the war in ukraine
the monarchy has its supporters and
indeed its critics but the power of
occasions such as this
the appeal across all walks of life
the party at the palace was staged on a
specially constructed 360 degree
platform right in front of the queen's
london home buckingham palace
22 000 ticket holders got the close-up
view but thousands more were watching
and listening from the surrounding
parkland and millions more on television
[Music]
two and a half hour concert in honor of
the queen's 70 years as the uk's head of
state
[Music]
the queen herself was never expected to
attend the concert her public
appearances increasingly limited by
physical frailty and mobility problems
nonetheless the tributes to her were
heartfelt and sincere
for 70 years you have worked so
incredibly hard not just for the people
of this country but for the whole
commonwealth windsor castle
is barely 20 miles away
so if we cheer loudly enough
she might
might just hear us
so
let's all join together
and amid the celebration and the sense
of historic occasion there is the
realization that this jubilee is likely
one of the last opportunities to
celebrate the reign of queen elizabeth
during her lifetime
paul brennan al-jazeera london